[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في هذه اللحظات عواصم في
العالم تعيش على وقع احداث مميزه هذه
الصور المباشره تاتينا من العاصمه
الاوكرانيه التي تستقبل اخبار جديده بشان
الامدادات الغربيه المحتمله لها على
الصعيد العسكري فيما يتواصل القصف الروسي
والمعارك في انحاء مختلفه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد بهذه الليله
في جده القمه العربيه الثانيه 32 تختتم
اعمالها باعلان يؤكد على مركزيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه ودعم المبادره العربيه للحل
دعوه عربيه لانهاء الصراع بالسودان وتثبيت
وقف اطلاق النار في اليمن وليبيا وعوده
اللاجئين السوريين وسرعه انتخاب رئيس في
لبنان
في تحقيق لبرنامج الجزيره ما خفي اعظم
الكشف عن تحقيقات اضافيه في قضيه اغتيال
الزميله شيرين ابو عقله
فريق نبني امريكي حقق في جنين وخلص الى ان
الرصاصات خرجت من القوه الاسرائيليه حصرا
ومسؤول اسرائيلي كبير اقر بنظراته
الامريكيين بقتل شيرين بالخطا واصر على
عدم الاعلان رسميا عن ذلك
في السودان اشتباكات مستمره في الخرطوم
وام درمان والخرطوم بحري وتصاعد للمعارك
في نيالا جنوبي دارفورد وبعد اكثر من شهر
على اندلاع المواجهات البرهان يعفي حميدتي
من منصب رئيس مجلس السياده ويعين زعيم
الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان ملك عقار
بدلا منه ويجري تغييرات في قياده الجيش
بعد مطالبات اوكرانيا للغرب بتزويدها
بطائرات اف 16 وتشكيل تحالف دولي للطائرات
المقاتله لاوكرانيا بريطانيا تعلن التوافق
مع دول غربيه على تزويد كيان بالقدره
الجويه القتاليه التي تحتاجها والبيت
الابيض يوافق على تدريب طيارين اوكرانيين
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا معكم التطورات في السودان
بعد اعلان رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي
عبد الفتاح البرهان اعفاء قائد قوات الدعم
السريه محمد حمدانو من منصب النائب الاول
لرئيسي مجلس السياده ليكلف بدلا منه مالك
عقار الزعيم الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير
السودان والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال الذي
يقول كيف يمكن قراءه القرارات الجديده
للبرهان سته وستون بالمئه قالوا انها
شكليه ولا تاثير لها بينما قال
34% ان هذه القرار ستؤثر على مسار
التطورات في البلاد
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
القمه العربيه الثانيه 32 اليوم باصدار
البيان الختامي الذي وافق عليه القاده
ورؤساء الوفود المشاركون في هذه القمه
البيان اكد على مركزيه القضيه الفلسطينيه
وتكثيف الجهود للتوصل الى تسويه عادله لها
وشدد البيان وجد على وقف التدخلات
الخارجيه في الشؤون الداخليه للدول
العربيه وعبر عن دعم مجلس القياده الرئاسي
في اليمن لاحلال الامن والاستقرار هناك
ودعا الى تكثيف الجهود العربيه الراميه
الى مساعده سوريا على تجاوز ازمتها وتعزيز
الظروف المناسبه لعوده اللاجئين السوريين
ودعى البيان الى الحيلوله دون اي تدخل
خارجي في الشان السوداني يؤجج الصراع واكد
اعلان جد كذلك ضروره حل الازمه الليبيه في
الاطار الليبي ودعم اجراء انتخابات
برلمانيه ورئاسيه كحل للخروج منها
وفي كلمته في الجلسه الافتتاحيه للقمه اكد
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
على مركزيه القضيه الفلسطينيه معربا عن
امله في ان تساهم عوده سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه في تحقيق الاستقرار فيها كما رحب
ولي العهد السعودي بتوقيع طرفي النزاع في
السودان على اعلان جده
الحضور الكرام من القضيه الفلسطينيه كانت
ولا زالت هي قضيه العرب والمسلمين
المحوريه
وتاتي على راس اولويات السياسات المملكه
الخارجيه ولم تتوان المملكه وتتاخر في دعم
الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق لاسترجاع اراضيه
واستعاده حقوقه مشروعه واقامه دوله
فلسطينيه مستقله ذات سياده على اراضي
الفلسطينيه بحدود عام 67 وعاصمتها القدس
الشرقيه وهم يسرنا اليوم حضور فخامه
الرئيس بشار الاسد لهذه القمه وصدور قرار
جامعه الدول العربيه بشان استئناف مشاركه
وفود الحكومه السوريه في اجتماعات مجلس
جامعه الدول العربيه ونامل ان يسهم ذلك في
دعم استقرار سوريا وعوده الامور لطبيعتها
واستئناف دورها الطبيعي في الوطن العربي
ما يحقق الخير لشعبها وما يدعم تطلعاتنا
جميعا نحو المستقبل افضل لمنطقتنا بما يخص
السودان نامل ان تكون لغه الحوار هي
الاساس الحفظ على وحده السودان وامن شعبه
المخدراته وفي هذا الصدد
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ترحب بتوقيع
طرفي نزاع على اعلان جده الالتزام بحمايه
مدنيين وتسهيل العمل الانساني ونامل
التركيز خلال هذه المحادثات على وقف فعال
لاطلاق النار
وقال الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس ان على
المجتمع الدولي ان يحمي الشعب الفلسطيني
من الجرائم الاسرائيليه
نعمل منكم جميعا
عامه الاخير وتقديم المرافعه
المكتوبه من قبل دوركم امام محكمه العدل
الدوليه على امل ان تصدر هذه المحكمه
رايها الاستشاري وفتواها حول قانونيه وشكل
واهليه النظام الذي اقامته اسرائيل دوله
الاحتلال والابقار التايد على ارض فلسطين
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد قال ان بلاده هي
قلب العروبه وان عروبتها انتماء لا عروبه
احضان
اما سوريا فمضيها وحاضرها ومستقبلها هو
العروبه لكنها عروبه انتماء لا عروبه
الاحضان فالاحضان عابره اما الانتماء
فدائم وربما ينتقل الانسان من حضن لاخر
لسبب ما لكنه لا يغير انتمائه اما من
يغيره فهو من دون انتماء من الاساس ومن
يقع في القلب لا يقبع في حضن وسوريا قلب
العروبه وفي قلبها
السيدات والساده
ونحن نعقل هذه القمه في عالم مضطرب فان
الامل يرتفع في ظل التقارب العربي العربي
والعربي الاقليمي والدولي والذي توج بهذه
القمه والتي اتمنى ان تشكل بدايه مرحله
جديده للعمل العربي للتضامن فيما بيننا
للسلام في منطقتنا للتنميه والازدهار بدلا
من الحرب والدمار
رئيس المجلس الرئاسي اليمني رشاد العليمي
قال انه يجب انهاء الانقلاب ضد المؤسسات
الدوله اليمنيه من قبل الميليشيات
المدعومه ايرانيا حسب تعبيره
تنعقد هذه القمه في وقت ما يزال فيه شعبنا
يعاني ويلات الحرب التي اشعلتها
الميليشيات الحوثيه منذ انقلابها على
التوافق الوطني في سبتمبر 2014 بدعم من
النظام الايراني المستميت من اجل استكمال
مشروعه التدمير في المنطقه مع استمرار
انقسام منظومتنا العربيه وعجزها عن
الاستجابه للازمات والنزاعات المسلحه التي
تهدد بانهيار الدوله الوطنيه
وتجريفها لصالح المشاريع الخارجيه
التوسعيه فاننا نامل تحركا عربيا جماعيا
الى جانب شقهنا في دول تحالف دعم الشرعيه
من اجل وقف تلك الانتهاكات للفظيعه
للقانون الدولي
ولقيام الاسلام والحريه والمساواه ودعم
جهود الحكومه اليمنيه لانعاش الاقتصاد
وتحسين الخدمات الاساسيه
رئيس الوفد السوداني السفير دفع الله
الحاج علي الذي مثل رئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان قال ان الجيش السوداني
سيختار السن اذا جناحت له من وصفها
بالقوات المتمرده في اشاره الى قوات الدعم
السريعه
نحن في حكومه السودان لسنا دعاه حرب لكنها
فرضت علينا واذا ما جنحت القوات المتمرده
للسلم سنجنح
له واذا وضعوا السلاح سيتم العفو عنهم بل
وان ابواب القوه القوات المسلحه السودانيه
مشرعه لدمجهم ان رغبوا
الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي قال ان
المنطقه تمر بظروف صعبه تحتاج الى حلول
حاسمه ويتطلب الامر تعاونا عربيا مشتركا
ان الاعتماد على جهودنا المشتركه وقدراتنا
الذاتيه والتكون فيما بيننا لصياغه حلول
حاسمه لقضايانا اصبح واجبا ومسؤوليه كما
ان تطبيق مفهوم العمل العربي المشترك
يتعين ان يمتد ايضا للتعامل مع الازمات
العالميه وتنسيق عملنا لصاحب منظومه
الحوكمه الاقتصاديه العالميه وفي القلب
منها مؤسسات التمويل وبنوك التنميه
الدوليه التي ينبغي ان تكون اكثر استجابه
لتحديات العالم النامي
هذا وتفتح عوده الرئيس السوري الى الجامعه
العربيه عده تساؤلات عن مستقبل القضايا
التي اثيرت مع ازمه سوريا قبل 12 عاما
منها ملف اللاجئين واعاده الاعمار والوجود
العسكريه والاجنبي في البلاد بالاضافه الى
الحوار الداخلي
في اسمها تبدو دوره عاديه للجامعه العربيه
دوره تحمل الرقم 32 في سياقها والحضور لا
تبدو كذلك بعد 12 عاما يحضر الرئيس السوري
للمره الاولى قبل هذه الاعوام قررت
الجامعه العربيه تجميد عضويه دمشق حينها
كانت الازمه في سوريا قد اندلعت وتحولت
حربا غيرت شكل البلاد طرحت العوده السوريه
الى مقعدها تساؤلات عما تغير في المشهد
السوري يفتح جلوس الاسد بين القاده العرب
الباب واسعا على عناصر مهمه واسئله عن
المرحله المقبله كيف سيصار الى حل ازمه
اللاجئين والنازحين الذين يقدرون
بالملايين جراء ما حل في بلادهم تساؤلات
عن اعاده الاعمار وسط بنيه تحتيه مدمره
وكذلك تساؤلات عن امكانيات اخراج قوات
اجنبيه من البلاد تحولت سوريا خلال
السنوات الماضيه الى قاعده عسكريه كبيره
بفعل الحرب دول كبرى في العالم والاقليم
وضعت جنودها على السوريه بعضها يعارض
النظام واخرون قاتلوا الى جانبه وتحولت
سوريا الى ساحه صراع اقليمي في ملف اللجوء
اكثر من خمسه ملايين
غادروا حدود بلادهم الى تركيا والاردن
ولبنان بدرجه اساسيه استقبلت اوروبا مئات
الالاف من اللاجئين السوريين نزح اكثر من
سته ملايين الى مناطق لا تخضع لسيطره
النظام يعتبر كثير من السوريين العوده الى
بلادهم الان كابوسا وقد تعالت الاصوات
اليمينيه في بعض الدول بضروره اعاده
السوريين الى وطنهم
[موسيقى]
هناك حيث قتل اكثر من 400 الف سوري بينهم
اكثر من عشرين الف طفل
[موسيقى]
عوده سوريا الى مقعدها في الجامعه العربيه
تلفت الانظار الى وضع البلاد استعاد
النظام السوري خلال السنوات القليله
الماضيه السيطره على اكثر من 70% من الارض
الا ان اعاده الاعمار وصلت الى طريق مسدود
بعد ان اقتربت فاتورتها من 400 مليار
دولار بحسب التقديرات السوريه والروسيه
شبكه الكهربائي وامدادات الوقود والمياه
والمدارس والمستشفيات كلها تضررت بنسب
متفاوته لكنها اصبحت في حكم المعدومه بحسب
مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه لا شريكا به يرفض الرئيس السوري
بتدخلات الخارجيه في الشؤون الداخليه
للدول العربيه هكذا يقول في كلمته ويميز
بين الحضن والانتماء
اما سوريا فمضيها وحاضرها ومستقبلها هو
العروبه لكنها عروبه انتماء لا عروبه
الاحضان فالاحضان عابره اما الانتماء
فدائم بعد عوده بشار الاسد لمقعده
بالجامعه العربيه تطرح التساؤلات ايضا في
هذه المرحله عن امكانيه الحوار الداخلي
بين المكونات السوريه هل يمكن ان يفضي الى
تفاهمات بعد كل هذه السنين
وينضم الينا من جده الدكتور خالد بطرفي
الاكاديميه والمحلل السياسي السعودي اهلا
وسهلا بيك دكتور لو قلنا ان
ان لا جديد في هذه القمه على الاطلاق الا
عوده سوريا وبشار الاسد هل هذا صحيح
هناك جديد ان العرب اتفقوا على ان ينبذوا
التدخلات الخارجيه وان يكون هناك موقفا
موحدا تجاه اي محاولات للهيمنه
والاستقطاب لهذه الدوله او تلك واعلنوا
الحياد في الصراع القائم بين القطبين
العسكر الشرقي والمعسكر الغربي واستضافه
الرئيس الاوكراني في رساله واضحه
للعالم بانهم ليسوا مع روسيا رغم انهم
بينهم وبين روسيا مصالح في اوبك وفي مجال
الطاقه وكانت لهم مواقف ترفض العقوبات
تنفيذ عقوبات على روسيا وفي نفس الوقت
اداعوا الرساله رساله بوتين للقمه
واستعداده للمساهمه
والصداقوا سوريا التي تمثل هذا المعسكر
جيدا العرب ارادوا ان يقولوا اننا في
مرحله الحياد الايجابي بين الشرق والغرب
ونصر على ذلك وفي نفس الوقت نرفض
الاملاءات ونرفض التدخلات بدليل انهم
رفضوا كل الضغوط الغربيه لمنع يعني اعاده
المقعد السوري
للحكومه السوريه واستقبال الرئيس بشار
الاصلي ولكن في هذه النقطه تحديدا يعني
يعني بغض النظر عن اي اعتبارات اخلاقيه او
مبدئيه نصف الشعب السوري نصف الشعب السوري
اما نازح او لاجئ لا شيء في هذه القمه بعث
له باي رساله طمانه يعني وكاننا المؤسسه
العربيه الرسميه تتضامن مع بعضها البعض
ولو على حساب عذابات الشعوب وهذه نقطه من
الصعب ان تغفل
بالعكس يعني عوده سوريا كانت مشروطه بعوده
اللاجئين وتامينهم وعدم معاقبه بعضهم ورفع
الاحكام على البعض الاخر والسماح للمعارضه
بالعوده والعوده الى المسار السني لو عدنا
الى البنود التي اعلنت في عمان واعلنت في
القاهره واعلنت مره اخرى في الاجتماعات
التحضيريه لراينا ان سوريا التزمت بكل ذلك
وعلى راس هذه القائمه عوده اللاجئين
وتيسير هذه العوده بدعم من الدول العربيه
لاعادتهم الى مدنهم ولكن في اسمح لي دكتور
اسمح لي دكتور فقط بهذه المقاطعه
دمشق لم تقم وزنا لاي قرارات من مجلس
الامن الدولي ومن قمم دوليه كبرى ستعير
اهتمام لمجلس جامعه الدول العربيه ولقاءات
عربيه الكل يعلم ان لا وزن لها يعني بغض
النظر عن عن اي حديث رسمي
لذلك كانت الاسلوب الذي سيتبع هو خطوه
مقابل خطوه يعني الان كل الذي حصلوا عليه
انهم عادوا الى الجامعه العربيه
ولكنهم لن يحصلوا على المساعدات التي
يبغونها على الاستثمارات وعلى الدعم وعلى
شرعنه النظام في المجتمع الدولي كل هذه
خطوات لاحقه ولكن الرئيس ولكن الرئيس
السوري في في كلمته لم يعطي ولا اشاره امل
ولا بارقه امل على امكانيه الاستجابه لهذه
لهذه الشروط التي تسميها لم يعطي اي اشاره
امل وبالتالي تحدث بلغه المنتصر ومن حقه
ربما ان يفعل ذلك لانه فعلا عاد من بوابه
كبرى من بوابه فرض شروطه وليس الاستجابه
لشروط الاخرين
يعني لا نحن لا ناخذ بالاقوال ولو اخذنا
بالاقوال انتهت المشكله السوريه منذ زمن
بعيد نحن ناخذ بالافعال
والمقابل الذي سيحصلون عليه ليس مقابل
وعود ولكن مقابل اعمال على الارض يعني
مكافحه المخدرات على سبيل المثال سوريا
اعطت احداثيات وسمحت بقصف يعني اكبر
عصابه للمخدرات على اراضيها
وتعاونت مع الاجهزه الامنيه في الاردن
والسعوديه وغيرها لمكافحه المخدرات على
اراضيها مكافحه الارهاب يعني هذه خطوه
تستحق في مقابلها
ما يتم الاتفاق عليه ثم هناك خطوات اخرى
ننتظرها قبل ان نفتح الحدود وقبل ان نقدم
الدعم وقدم قبل ان ندع نقدم المساعدات ثم
من هو ما هو البديل الذي يسالني ويقول ان
ان علينا ان لا نغامر ولا نفعل ولا نقدم
اي مبادره ما البديل يعني 12 عاما كانت
كلها على حساب السوريين
البلد وعلى حسب
التضامن العربي شكرا لك دكتور خالد بطرفي
من جده شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
كشف برنامج الجزيره التحقيقيه ما خفي اعظم
الذي تم بثه الليله ان مسؤولا اسرائيليا
كبيرا في مكتب وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي سبق
بني قانس اعترف لمسؤولين امريكيين ان
الرصاصه التي قتلت الزميله شيرين ابو عقله
اطلقها فعلا جندي يونس اسرائيلي وقال مصدر
اطلع على هذا الاعتراف للبرنامج ان
المسؤوله الاسرائيلي قال ان قتل شيرين كان
خطا لكنه اصر على ان اسرائيل لن تعلن ذلك
او تعترف به رسميا بالاطار ذاته حصل مخافي
اعظم على وثائق من تحقيقات اسرائيليه في
قضايا قتل صحفيين في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
كشفت حجم التلاعب الاسرائيلي في التحقيقات
والتهرب من المسؤوليه والافلات من العقاب
المحقق والخبير الامريكي ستيفن باك هو
الرجل الذي تولى مهمه تحليل المقاطع
الصوتيه لحادثه اغتيال الزميله شيرين ابو
عاقله
عرض ستيفن باك المستشار السابق لمكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي اف بي اي في مقابلته
الخاصه مع برنامج الجزيره التحقيق ما خفي
اعظم نتائج تحليلاته التي حسمت الجدل حول
مطلق النار الذي استهدف الزميله شيرين في
جنين
وفقا لحسابات فقد كان مطلق النار على بعد
ما بين 180 مترا الى 200 متر واكتشفنا
ايضا ان هناك مجموعه من جنود جيش الدفاع
الاسرائيلي كانوا على بعد 200 متر من ذلك
التقاطع حيث كانت الصحفيه والمصور لذا فان
بصمه الصوت تتطابق مع المسافه وتلك
الرصاصات كانت تتجه نحو الصحفي وعليه
اعتقد جازما ان ذلك يدعم حقيقه مفادها ان
اطلاق النار جاء من جنود الجيش الاسرائيلي
مصدر رفيع المستوى اطلع على الاتصالات بين
المسؤولين الامريكيين والاسرائيليين كشف
لما خفي اعظم ان مسؤولا اسرائيليا كبيرا
في مكتب وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي السابق
بنجانس اعترف بما لا يضع مجالا للشك
لمسؤولين امريكيين ان الرصاصه التي قتلت
الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله هي رصاصه
اسرائيليه وانها كانت نتيجه خطا لكنه اصر
على ان اسرائيل لن تعترف وتعلن ذلك رسميا
تحقيق ما خفي اعظم الذي حمل عنوان قتل
الادله عرض وثائق من التحقيقات
الاسرائيليه التي وثقت عمليات التلاعب
الممنهج بقضايا قتل واستهداف الصحفيين في
فلسطين على يد جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
والتهرب من المسؤوليه والعقاب الشهيدان
الصحفيان فضل شناعه وياسر مرتجى من غزه
والشهيد الصحفي نزيه دروزه من نابلس وثق
ما خفي اعظم كيف تم اقفال ملفات قتلهم
اثناء تغطياتهم الاعلاميه دون محاسبه
وايضا اخفاء ادله اغتيالهم كما وثق
التحقيق بالوثائق معاناه الصحفي معاذ
عمارنه الذي فقد عينه برصاصه جندي
اسرائيلي وما زال شاهدا على تبرئه الجنود
من اي مسؤوليه او عقاب في قضيه قتل اخرى
للصحفي البريطاني جيمس ميلر في رفح عام
ذهبت الحكومه الاسرائيليه الى دفع تعويض
مالي كبير للعائله
على وقع ضغط من الحكومه البريطانيه في
مشهد يظهر ازدواجيه المعايير
اليوم العين على محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
التي رفعت امامها شبكه الجزيره قضيه
اغتيال شيرين ابو عاقله كما رفعت نقابه
الصحفيين الفلسطينيين والاتحاد الدولي
للصحفيين قضيه اخرى تتضمن ملف شيرين
وصحفيين اخرين خطوه تبحث عن العداله وان
كان المسار حتى اللحظه لا يبعث على
التفاؤل لدى البعض من الواضح من المدعي
العام المحكمه الجمعيه الدوليه
السيد كريم خان من الواضح انه يمارس سته
السيس والانتقائيه بصوره كامله في التعامل
مع الملف الفلسطيني لم يتحرك مليمتر واحد
حتى في مستوى الاتصال والتواصل مع
المحامين او مع الضحايا او زياره المناطق
او حتى اعطاء تصريح واحد عما يدور في
الاراضي المحتله من جرائم حرب وجرائم ضد
الانسانيه تواصل فريق البرنامج مع مكتب
المدعي العام للجنايات الدوليه بحثا عن
مقابله حول مصير قضايا قتل الصحفيين في
فلسطين فجاء الرد لن نستطيع اجراء مقابله
بهذا الخصوص
متابعه لهذا الموضوع معنا من فيينا
الخبير او المدير التنفيذي بالاحرى للمعهد
الدولي للصحافه ومن واشنطن عمر شاكر مدير
منظمه هيوند في اسرائيل وفلسطين اهلا
بضيفين نبدا بالسيد عمر شاكر هل معنى ذلك
وفق ما تبعناه في تحقيق الجزيره ان لا امل
في اللجوء الى القضاء سواء الاسرائيلي او
الدولي في ملاحقه قتل الصحفيين
دعونا نكون واضحين تماما فان كل الادله
تشير الى ان القوات الاسرائيليه هي التي
قتلت
الصحفيه شيرين ابو عاقله
وباستخدام قوه غير قانونيه كما فعلت من
قبل لقتل فلسطينيين وصحفيين
وهذه الانتهاكات كلها جبهت لسنوات والعقود
من انفلات من العقاب وهذه المحاسبه يجب ان
تكون من الجهات الدوليه مثل المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه
المجال الوحيد الذي اختلفوا فيه هو هو ان
التحقيق ما زال مستمرا من قبل الجنائي
الدوليه ونامل من المدعي العام للمحكمه ان
يصدر مذكرات اعتقال في كل من يتهموا
بحوادث وجرائم مثل هذه ولكن سيد شاكر كيف
تامل ذلك والمدعي العام لم يكلف نفسه حتى
عناء ان يعطي تصريح لصاحب البرنامج او ان
يرد على ايميل او ان يشرع حتى في بعض
الاتصالات مع اسرائيليين
هذا هو السبب للشعور بالقلق
للشك هل ان المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
ستعمضي قدما الى الامام فلم تصدر عنها
تصريحات او عن مدعي العام كما كان الحال
مع العام السابق لكن مع ذلك القضيه تبقى
قضيه مفتوحه والمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
تستمر في عملها احيانا راينا ان هذه
القضاء قد تاخذ سنوات مع بنسوده عندما
استغرق الامر سنوات في قضاء سابقه لكن في
النهايه سوف نحكم من خلال النتائج وما
تزال هناك احتماليه ان تمضي القضيه الى
الامام وان تصدر ومذكرات اعتقال والمده
العام قال انه يخطط لزياره فلسطين هذا
العام نامل ان يتم ذلك وان تصدر مذكرات
الاعتقال اللفت للنظر سيد ماروفيت في
فيينا
ما ورد في التقرير بان
اسرائيل على لسان مسؤوليها في وزاره
الدفاع اعترفت
الامريكيين بان فعلا الرصاصه كانت
اسرائيليه ولكنها لن تعترف بذلك علنا ولن
تعتذر عليه
كيف تفهم مثل هذا الموقف
اولا اعتقد انها امر مريع حقيقه ان نحتفل
بالذكرى السنويه الاولى لقتل الشيرين وما
زال قتلتها من دون محاسبه واحرار ايضا
الصوت يتقطع من المصدر الصوت يتقطع اتفضل
ايضا كان هناك تصريح من مسؤول عسكري
اسرائيل يقول انهم يعتذرون عن ذلك هذه
كلها خطوات مهمه الى الامام لكنها ليست
محاسبه عن قتل الصحفي وواضح من الادله
والتي تم توفيرها
للمدعي العام وانا كنت مشاركا مع محامي
الجزيره ومراسلين بلا حدود عندما قدمنا
الادله للمدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه
باننا انهم سيتابعون القضيه ونحن من
جانبين علينا ان نستمر
بالمطالبه لكي يتخذ المتعه العام اجراءاته
وايضا
في الماضي قتل الكثير من الصحافيين
الاخرين التي وقعت في هذه الاراضي ايضا
سيد من خلال البرنامج
نرى ان مثلا وكاله كبيره مثل الاسيو
لم تفعل شيئا لصحافيه الذي قتل وان
بريطانيا حصلت على مؤسسه بريطانيه حصلت
على تعويض مالي لقتل احد صحفية في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه بينما لا احد يهتم بصحفي
فلسطيني هل هذا ايضا مدعاه للقلق
لست متاكدا من القول بانه لا احد يهتم نحن
نهتم ومنظمات الصحافه تهتم المطالبين
بحقوق الجزيره تهتم الجزيره حسب علمي ايضا
تبذل الجهودا كبيره وهناك الكثير ممن
يهتمون انا عملت منذ سنوات في ملاحقه
قضايا قتل صحفيين لم تتحقق العداله في
بعضها الا بعد مضيء ثلاثين عاما الامر
يحتاج الى فتره طويله لكن علينا ان نصبر
ونثابر
ونضمن ان المسؤولين عن هذا الافعال لن
يشعر ابدا بانهم سينجونا ويفلتون من
العقاب وهذا في ضوء ايضا المجتمع الدولي
والمجتمع الصحفي في العالم علينا ان نضمن
من جانبنا اننا
والمجتمع الدولي والمؤسسات الصحفيه
الدوليه لن نتخلى ليس عن هذه القضيه لكن
عن كل القضايا الاخرى للصحفيين الذين قد
قتلوا سيد عمر شاكر 30 عاما ربما علينا ان
ننتظر في بعض القضايا اليس هذا محبطا
من الواضح تماما كما اوضح المتحدث الاخر
بان العمليه محبطه وسنوات والتمر وعقود
تمر
واجيال من الفلسطينيين اضطر للعيش تحت ظله
حكم احتلال عسكري وايضا
الجرائم الحرب والاتهاكات الصارخه التي
التي ارتكبت في غزه وغيرها تمر بدون عقاب
هذه مساله في غايه المهمه ليس فقط على
صعيد المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بل على
صعيد المحاكم الوطنيه
وايضا الذين هم ما زالوا ما زالت هذه
الجرائد الجرائم ترتكب يجب ان نضع حدا لكل
هذا وكما لاحظ المتحدث الاخر فان
المجتمع الدولي والمنظمات الدوليه الصحفيه
وغيرها والفلسطينيين ايضا والرغبه عقود من
القمع عليهم ان يستمروا ونستمر معهم لان
جميع يطالب بكل شجاعه يوم امس فقط في
واشنطن العاصمه كانت هناك مطالبات بمحاكمه
المسؤولين سيد في النهايه باختصار هل يمكن
التعويل كذلك على منظمات حقوق الانسان
الاسرائيليه في هذا الموضوع
امل ان نستطيع
اعتماد على الاسرائيلين ايضا لان هم الذين
يستطيعون فرض ضغوط على حكومتهم لكن دعوني
اضيف شيئا فان الاعتداء على صحفي في ظل
نزاع مسلح يرقى الى مستوى جرائم الحرب
ايضا علينا ان لا ننسى ذلك ومن ثم فان
هناك
واجب بان الاراضي المحتله هذه القوه
الاحتلال عليها واجب حمايه ارواح الناس
وطبعا الصحفيين منهم ايضا شكرا لك سيدي
شكرا لك سيد عمر شاكر من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
في السودان اقالها قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
البرهان قائد قوات الدعم السريع من منصبه
نائبا لرئيس مجلس السياده وعين مكانه رئيس
الحركه الشعبيه ملك عقار فيما يستمر
القتال بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
العاصمه الخرطوم وبعض مناطق البلاد
للوسطات السياسيه وللاتفاقيات الانسانيه
نجحت حتى اللحظه في ارساء تهدئه في
السودان
ومع اصوات القتال تخفض الدبلوماسيه او
هكذا يفهم من المشهد الميداني الذي يزداد
تعقيدا في خطوه متوقعه عاد قائد الجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان خلط بعض اوراق مجلس
السياده الانتقالي المختلف عليه اصلا
واجلس سلسله تعيينات جديده في هرم القياده
العسكريه في مرسوم دستوري اصدره البرهان
اقال نائبه وخصمه قائد الدعم السريع من
منصبه نائبا لرئيس مجلس السياده وعين رئيس
الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان مالك عغار
بدلا منه نائبا لرئيس المجلس وعين الفريق
اول ركن شمس الدين كباشي نائبا للقائد
العام للقوات المسلحه والفريق اول ركن
ياسر العطا مساعدا للقائد العام للقوات
المسلحه والفريق بحري مهندس ابراهيم جابر
مساعدا للقائد العام
القوات المسلحه ميدانيا افاد مراسل
الجزيره ان الطائرات الجيش قصفت مواقع
لقوات الدعم السريع في حي شامبات ومناطق
شمال الخرطوم مع تحليق مكثف للمقاتلات في
سماء العاصمه لاسيما ام درمان والخرطوم
بحري ويقول الجيش ان قوته مستمره في تنشيط
الاحياء في منطقه ابو حمامه بالعاصمه ورصد
مراسل الجزيره دخول اليات عسكريه للجيش
السوداني الى الخرطوم وقال مصدر عسكري
بالجيش ان الاليات استقدمت من قياده
المدفعيه بمدينه عطبره شمالي البلاد وفي
نيال جنوب دارفور تجددت الاشتباكات بين
الجيش والدعم السريع مع ورود انباء عن
سقوط اصابات واتهمت قوات الدعم السريع
الجيش بقصف عدد من الاحياء السكنيه
بالمدافع الثقيله في المدينه
وسط ذلك تتفاقم الازمه الانسانيه المتحدث
باسم المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين قال ان اكثر من مليون شخص
نزحوا ولجاوا حتى الان بسبب القتال
لينضموا الى الالاف الذين سبقوهم في ماسي
اللجوء المستمره في السودان منذ سنوات
معنا هنا في الاستوديو سيد ضياء الدين
بلال كاتب صحفي والمحلل السياسي السوداني
اهلا وسهلا بك هذه التغييرات الكثيره في
مجلس السياده كيف يمكن فهمها هي مجموعه من
القرارات التي اتخذت من قبل المتعلقه
قرارات اقتصاديه وقرارات سياسيه وقرارات
عسكريه فبالتالي هي محاوله لعكس الصوره
بان الاوضاع العسكريه لم تعد كما كانت لو
ان الضغوطات التي كانت تمارس على قياده
الجيش خفت الى قدر كبير فبالتالي خرجت
قياده الجيش من خارج الصندوق القتالي
واصبحت تنظر الى امور اخرى متعلقه
بالجوانب السياسيه والمتعلقه بالجوانب
الاقتصاديه واعتقد ان ذلك مترتب للتطورات
التي حدثت في الميدان
ازاحه
حميتي هل تعني ان الموضوع حسم بالكامل على
هذا السعيد تعطي مؤشرات كذلك تعطي مؤشرات
بانها الان لم يعد كما كان
والمتغيرات
العسكريه بالاضافه الى ان هنالك كثير من
الاقاويل التي تردد بان حميدتي الان مصاب
والرغم ان هنا لا توجد تاكيدات حاسمه ولكن
واضح ان الغياب حميدتي بشكل كبير والرغم
المواقف ورغم القرارات ورغم الكثير من من
الامور التي كانت تستدعي ان يخرج ويتحدث
كل هذا الغياب ربما يعطي مؤشر بان حميتي
الان في تقدير الجيش لم يعد بذات الوضع
القديم ولكن ازاحه تحميل في حين تجري
مساعي في جده لترتيب
انا نقول تسويه ولكن تفاهمات معينه بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه لا يعرقل ذلك
التفاهمات التفاهمات الطبيعه الانسانيه
كما حدثت قياده الجيش من اول يوم بان
الامر لا يتعلق بالبعد السياسي ولا يتعلق
بالجوانب العسكريه ولكن يتعلق فقط
بالجوانب الانسانيه
المرتبطه
بالممرات الامنه
والمرتبطه باخلاء الاماكن السكنيه
والاماكن الحيويه والمستشفيات فبالتالي لا
اعتقد ان هنالك تعارضا كبيرا بين هذه
القرارات وبين مجرى التفاوضات الذي يبدو
الى الان متعسرا بعض الشيء لم يتقدم خطوه
على ما تم الاعلان عنه
وانصاره كانوا دائما يرددون بان مؤسسه
الجيش يسيطر عليها التيار الاسلامي
والاخوان المسلمون هذه التغييرات في
المجلس يمكن ان تكرس مثل هذا الانطباع او
تبعده هذه هذه
الحزب التوصيف يتم تسويقه او على الاقل لم
يتم شرائه من قطاعات واسعه بان هذه
القيادات الموجوده الان في الجيش معروفه
بعدم ارتباطها بالتنظيمات الاسلاميه اذا
كان الفريق البرهان او الفريق الكباشي او
الفريق يصل العطاء هؤلاء ليس لهم صلات
بالتنظيمات الاسلاميه فبالتالي اعتقد ان
ذلك ليس له انعكاس على على تعضيض هذا
الاتهام او او نفي باعتبار ان هذا الاتهام
هو اتهام سياسي في حد ذات الاستخدام
لاستخدام الامر في الجوانب التسويق
الخارجي خاصه اقليميا بان يستثير غضب بعض
الاطراف الاقليميه التي لها مواقف معاديه
للتيارات الاسلاميه شكرا جزيلا لك سيد
ضياء الدين بلال على حضورك معنا شكرا لك
الان معنا من واشنطن الدكتور الخليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه والباحث في المركز العربي في
واشنطن الملف السوداني كان ايضا حاضرا
دكتور خليل العناني في قمه جده هل وجدت
ايه مؤشرات على تحرك عربي فعال في هذا
الملف
لا اعتقد ذلك على الاطلاق ما حدث لقامه
العربيه اليوم مجرد فقط كلام عام حول اولا
اتكيت على اللغه الحوار واتهدابا الطرفين
المتحاربين في السودان الامر الثاني متعلق
برفض تدخل الخارجي في هذه الازمه الامر
متعلق بالبناء ودعم ما حدث في المفاوضات
جده بشكل عام من الصعب الحديث عن وجود خطه
عمليه عربيه من اجل التعاطف على الموقف
السوداني جزء منه متعلق اولا بان بعض
الاطراف العربيه متورطه بشكل او باخر في
الصراع في السودان لديها مصالح متعارضه
متصارعه هناك جزء اخر متعلق متعلق على
قلعه هذه اللحظه بعدم على الطرفين
المتحاربين الدخول في مفاوضات مباشره من
اجل حل الصراع ما يحدث الان من فقدته
محركات في جده متعلق فقط بالبعد الانساني
وحتى هذا البعد الانساني غير مستحق هذه
اللحظه هناك اشتباكات كما سمعنا قبل قليل
في التقرير اشتباكات في الخرطوم وفي
الفاشل في دارفور وفي مناطق اخرى هناك
ازمه انسانيه غير مسبوقه بنتكلم على الاقل
على 4000 حتى هذه اللحظه اكثر من 4000
عفوا 4000 مصاب نعم بتتكلم على حتى هذه
اللحظه ملايين الاشخاص في حاجه لمساعده
الانسانيه عاجله بلون شخص تم تجزيره تم
تهجيره او يعني نازحين وبالتالي ما
انسانيه متفاقمه الى حد بعيد لا اعتقد ان
هناك امكانيه عربيه تدخل في هذه الازمه من
حال العمليه
لم تقم بحل اي عدد ازمه عربيه سواء كان في
ليبيا او في اليمن او في سوريا والان في
السودان للاسف الشديد الاشاره الى رفض
التدخل الخارجي في الموضوع السوداني هل
يمكن ان يفهم ضمنا ولو كان هذا التدخل
عربيا كما اشارت بعض التقارير في موضوع
السودان تحديدا
اعتقد ذلك احد الاطراف الرئيسيه في السرعه
الحالي في السودان هو اطراف عربيه
تقوم بدعم طرف مقابل طرف اخر وابرز مثلا
دعم الاماراتي لحامتي ليس فقط دعما
دبلوماسيا دعما دبلوماسيا بعد تقرير تحدث
عن دعم عسكري ودعم استخبار دعم لوجستي
هناك ايضا موقف داعم من اسرائيل لحامتي
وهناك حتى الموضوع هناك حديث حول دعم مصري
للبرهان وبالتالي المقصود بالاطراف
الخارجيه بالاساس انا في رايي الشخص يعترف
عربيه طبعا هناك اطراف خارجيه مثلا هناك
تدخل روسي من خلال قوات فاجنر ودعمها بشكل
او باخر لحبيبتي خاصه في ظل وجود علاقات
طويله المدى بين الطرفين فيما يتعلق سواء
بتهريب الذهب في متعلق باستخدام المرتزقه
في المثلث الحدود بين تشاد وليبيا
والسودان
المواقف الدوليه دكتور خليل العناني
الولايات المتحده قبل فتره وعلى لسان
بايدن اشارت الى ان الموضوع له علاقه حتى
بالامن القومي الامريكي بعد هذا التصريح
لم نرى شيئا على صعيد التحرك العملي في
هذا الملف
هذا صحيح منذ اول يوم استاذ محمد وهناك
التعويل امريكا كبير جدا على اطراف
الخارجيه من اجل التدخل في هذا النزاع
وهناك التعويل خاصه على الامارات
والسعوديه واسرائيل ومصر الى حد هناك
قناعه امريكيه بان الازمه في السودان فقط
ازمه محليه او ازمه ازمه داخليه ازمه ايضا
لها بعد اقليمي بشكل او باخر الامر الاخر
متعلق باهميه السودان لامريكا تعتبر
السودان دوله استراتيجيه مهمه سواء
لمساحتها الكبيره جدا اكبر دوله في
افريقيا لدي حدود مع سبع دول على الاقل
والاكثر من ذلك انها دوله لديها حدود
استراتيجيه مع دول القرن الافريقي وبتتكلم
على هذه المنطقه حلوه جدا لامريكا ليس فقط
من اجل الامن القومي لامريكا ايضا من اجل
الصراع مع الصين ومع روسيا ايضا شكرا لك
دكتور خليل العناني من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
دخلت وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه عن مصدر في
البيت الابيض دعم الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن تدريب طيارين اوكرانيين على طائرات
اف 16 ياتي ذلك في وقت قال رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ان بلاده وهولندا ستعملان مع
الولايات المتحده وبلجيكا لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالقدره الجويه القتاليه التي تحتاجها
الحديث عن طائرات اف 16 يتزامن مع تطورات
ميدانيه مستمره تتركز في مناطق الشرق
والجنوب الاوكراني
كما هو الحال في كل يوم منذ بدايه حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا تحتدم المعارك بين
الجانبين وتتعرض الاستراتيجيات العسكريه
لكليهما للاختبار في الميدان الملتهب
القوات الروسيه وصلت هجماتها المكثفه على
منطقه كييف بالطائرات المسيره والصواريخ
وقالت الاداره الاقليميه للمنطقه ان
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه اسقطت عددا من
المسيرات فوق غابات المقاطعه
من ناحيه اخرى تؤكد روسيا استمرار
عملياتها في محاور لمن وباخمت ومارينكا
ومحيطها وان اعنف الاشتباكات جرت في باخمت
ومارينكا وان مدفعيتها الثقيله دمرت
مجموعتين من القوات الاوكرانيه في باخموت
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني اعترفت بان
القوات الروسيه تحقق التقدما في باخموت
لكنها لم تسيطر عليها وان معارك عنيفه
تدور في ضواحي المدينه الجنوبيه الغربيه
كذلك تحدث مصدر عسكري روسي عن استهداف
نقاط انتشاري من سماهم بالمرتزقه والقوات
الخاصه في مناطق بدونيتسك الخاضعه للسيطره
الروسيه وتكون مراسله الجزيره ان القصف
الاوكراني استهدف وسط دونيسك واحياء محيطه
بها في اقليم الدومباس في شرق اوكرانيا
وفي محور شبه جزيره القرم تقول السلطات
الروسيه ان دفاعياتها اسقطت مسيرات في
الشمال وتزامن ذلك مع اتهام مجلس الامن
القومي الروسي للمخابرات الامريكيه
بالتورط في تفجير جسر القرم وخط انابيب
الغاز نورد ستريم وهجمات ارهابيه اخرى جرت
اخيرا
في هذه الاثناء ابلغ الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن قاده مجموعه السبع المجتمعين في
هيروشيما دعمه لمبادره مشتركه تهدف الى
تدريب طيارين اوكرانيين على طائرات مقاتله
من الجيل الرابع بما يشمل مقاتلات 16
ويقول البيت الابيض انه خلال فتره التدريب
تلك سيقرر تحالف الدول المشاركه في هذا
الجهد موعد تقديم الطائرات وعددها ومن
سيقدمها
وتربط اوساط مختلفه نجاح اي هجوم واسع
يمكن ان تنفذه القوات الاوكرانيه ضد مواقع
روسيه متقدمه بالتفاصيل الميدانيه الدقيقه
لتلك المواقع فمثل ذلك الهجوم اذا وقع
سيكون اختبارا حقيقيا لفاعليه المساعدات
العسكريه الكبيره التي قدمتها وتقدمها دول
الناتو لاوكر انيا وهو امر تدرك ابعاده
القيادات العسكريه في اوكرانيا
وتتحسب له روسيا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حديث بايدن عن طائرات اف 16 وتدريب
الطيارين الاوكرانيين جاء كذلك خلال قمه
مجموعه السبع التي اعلن فيها قاده
المجموعه فرض عقوبات جديده على روسيا تشمل
منعها من الحصول على التقنيات المطوره في
الدول الاعضاء في هذه المجموعه
قبل بدء القمه تذكرت المدينه ماساتها
القديمه فهذا المبنى هو الوحيد الذي صمد
في وجه القنبله الذريه التي القيت على
هيروشيما قبل نحو 80 عاما
حرصت اليابان على ان يزوره القاده قبل
انطلاق اجتماعهم وبينهم للمفارقه رئيس
الولايات المتحده البلد المسؤول عن القاء
هذه القنبله
رمزيه المكان لا تخفى في سياق دولي عاد
فيه الخطر النووي الى الواجهه صمت التنكر
اختياره هيروشيما ليس مصادفه فبمجرد نطق
كلمه هيروشيما يذكر بالقصف النووي وهذا
يحمل عنوانا لهذه القمه مفاده ان القاده
المشاركين هنا هم ضد استخدام السلاح
النووي
وذاك ما قيل تصريحا قبل القمه وخللها
فالقاده اعلنوا انهم لا يقبلون اي تهديد
باستخدام السلاح النووي ورسالتهم في ذلك
موجهه الى روسيا التي فرضوا عليها دون
مفاجاه عقوبات جديده
يقول بيان القمه ان العقوبات الجديده تهدف
الى حرمان روسيا من التكنولوجيا التي تدعم
قدراتها العسكريه كما ترون منعها من
الالتفاف على العقوبات المفروضه عليها
سابقا واضافه قطاعات جديده اخرها تجاره
الالماس لانه
نركز الان على اغلاق الباب في وجه الثغرات
والاستمرار في قطع الامدادات الحيويه عن
روسيا سنقيد التجاره بالالماس الروسي الذي
لم يدوم الى الابد
واذا كان الاجتماع قد حقق المطلوب منه
بشان الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وقدم
المشاركون فيه تعهدا بدعمها ماليا وعسكريا
وانسانيا فالامر يبدو مختلفا بالنسبه
للعلاقه مع الصين فالرئيس الفرنسي يصل الى
القمه بعد اسابيع قليله من تحذيره مما
وصفها لسياسه التبعيه للولايات المتحده
فيما يخص الموقف من الصين وتوتر علاقاتها
مع تايوان
لكن الموقف الفرنسي هذه المره حرص على عدم
اظهار ما يمكن ان يفهم على انه خلاف بشان
الصين صحيح ان اعلن انها لن تكون قمه
موجهه ضد الصين لكنه شدد في الوقت ذاته
على ان مجموعه السبع ستوضح للصين
اشتراطاتها من اجل التعاون
وكعادته قمم مجموعه السبع لم تمر هذه
القمه دون احتجاجات
مناهض الراسماليه والامبرياليه خرجوا
لاعلان رفضهم للقمه ولما سيصدر عنها لكن
صوتهم وكالعاده ايضا بقي حبيس الشوارع
الخلفيه حيث حيل بينهم وبين الوصول الى
مقر القمه ما بين حرب مشتعله واخرى تنظر
بالاشتعال تنعقد هذه القمه في سياق دولي
سميته التصعيد والواضح ان التوتر لن ينتهي
قريبا فقدت السبع اجتمعوا في هيروشيما
لتوحيد موقفهم من روسيا ومن الصين لا
لتغييره محمد البقالي الجزيره هيروشيما
[موسيقى]
دائما ما تتكرر الاسئله بشان طائرات اف 16
التي كانت حاضره في تصريحات الدول الداعمه
لاوكرانيا اليوم ولماذا كل هذا الاصرار
عليها كعامل التغيير في مسار المعارف هنا
نسال تحديدا لماذا تريد كياب هذا النوع من
الطيران الجواب لان هذه الطائرات اثبتت
التمتعها بكفاءه عاليه في المعارك فهي
خفيفه ولديها قدرات على القتال الجوي
وتنفيذ ضربات ارضيه اما السمه الاهم بحسب
الخبراء العسكريين فهي انها متعدده المهام
لكن تمت محددات لا يمكن التقليل من شانها
تتحكم بمدى تاثيرها في ميزان المعارك
اهمها تدريب الطيارين والاسلحه التي ستزود
بها وطراز المعدات الالكترونيه المضافه
اليها هذه المعطيات ستحدد سعر وقيمه وقدره
هذه الطائرات وفي حال تم تزويد اوكرانيا
بها فستكون المانيا وبريطانيا وبولندا هي
المصدر الرئيسي الى جانب دول اخرى لكن ذلك
سيخضع لحساب دقيق جدا نظرا لمخاوف امريكيه
من وقوعها بايدي الروس لكن ما الذي تملكه
اوكرانيا بالاساس من المقاتلات بحسب تقرير
نشر بدايه هذا العام فان عدد الطائرات
المقاتله التي كانت تملكها كييف تبلغ نحو
200 تقريبا منها قرابه مئه وخمسه وعشرين
طائره من طراز ميغ تسعه وعشرين وسوء وسبعه
وعشرين لكنها خسرت نحو نصف هذه الطائرات
خلال المعارك لاحقا زودت سلوفاكيا
اوكرانيا بعدد من مقاتلات تسعه وعشرين من
اصل 13 طائره وعدت بارسالها فيما سلمت
بولندا تسعه طائرات بعد ان وعدت بارسال كل
مخزونها من طائرات ميج 29 والبالغ قرابه
30 طائره
معنا الان من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا
بك لنفترض ان طائرات اف 16 وصلت فعلا ثياب
الان ماذا ستفعل بها
يعني هو اضافه نوعيه
لانها تؤهلها لخوض ما يطلق عليها بالمعركه
المشتركه بل بحر جو وهذا هو السعي
الاوكراني ان تكون المعركه الهجوم القادم
ليس هجوما بريا فقط انما تحت عنوان
المعركه المشتركه تكون فيها العناصر
الثلاثه الرئيسيه البر والبحر والجو تعمل
بتكامل وعند ذلك يمكن ان تحقق انجازات
ميدانيه يعتد بها وتقود الى طاوله التفاوض
الابسط تتعشر عندما تدخل المعارك كيف
ستغير المعادله الحربيه
طائره
اف 16 هي طائره التفوق الجوي تتميز كما
ذكرت ولكن من اهم مميزاتها القدره على
المناوره صغر الحجم التسارع الايجابي حتى
في الاتجاه العمودي وهي طائره التفوق جوي
اي بمعنى اخر ستمكن من تامين الحمايه
الجويه في المعركه المشتركه للقوات
الارضيه المتقدمه وهي تتفوق على الطائرات
الروسيه من طراز ميك 29 وسوء 30 وما شابه
ذلك اذا وصولها لكن بشرط اعداد كافيه
ومنظومه امداد وطيارين مؤهلين وتقنيه
متقدمه من
الاصدار الخامس ستحدث فرقا واضحا ليست
واشنطن هي من ستمد كييف مباشره دول اخرى
المانيا
بولندا بريطانيا لماذا عبر وسطاء بتقديرك
اعتقد ان السبب تم التصريح عنه من الجانب
الامريكي ان الموازن المخصصه لدعم
اوكرانيا من قبل الامريكيين اذا ما تم
تزويدهم بطائرات اف 16
ستستهلك معظم المخصصات الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا هنا ستجيز باعاده التصدير
وبمعنى اخر التكلفه ستكون على حساب الدول
المصدره وليس على حساب الرصيد الامريكي
المخصص للدعم الاوكراني
شكرا جزيلا لك لو فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من عمان
بهذا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد دمتم في رعايه
الله وتصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]